[Música]
hoy en directo vamos a El Salvador
porque desde este martes los youtubers
del país están autorizados para cubrir
las sesiones de la asamblea legislativa
fue una decisión que llegó hace poco y
que según el presidente del Congreso es
clave para que estos creadores de
contenido relaten la verdad pues aseguró
que previamente el monopolio de medios
que controlaba la información en el país
tergiversaba esa realidad en San
Salvador conectamos con Vladimir
Chamorro les corresponsal de France 24
Vladimir Qué consecuencias trae que los
youtubers no sólo tengan permiso para
cubrir las sesiones de la asamblea sino
que sean los abanderados del gobierno
para hacerlo
bueno en primer lugar hay que decir que
este tipo de canales de comunicación
digital no están sujetos a criterio de
verificación de información como es el
caso de los medios de comunicación
tradicional por lo que existe un riesgo
de que esta información que se brinde no
se maneje de forma responsable hay que
considerar y tener en cuenta también de
que este segmento de comunicación
digital es una de las principales piezas
de apalancamiento del actual del actual
gobierno y de la figura específicamente
del presidente bukele Esto es lo que
ahora se quieren emular Desde la
asamblea legislativa sin embargo
el tratamiento y la relación de este
órgano de estado el primer órgano de
estado no es muy buena y no ha sido muy
buena desde que se cuenta con una
mayoría oficialista por ejemplo
hay restricciones al acceso de
información oficiosa que se solicita
por ejemplo de adjudicaciones de
contrato salarios esa información no
Pese que oficiosamente debería de de
otorgarse Pues muchas veces el el
principal órgano de estado en la niega
entonces ahí hay una contrariedad Bueno
y qué reacciones se han producido en El
Salvador ante esta nueva medida
bueno esta medida pues obviamente ha
sido criticada el presidente ha dicho de
la asamblea legislativa Ernesto Castro
ha dicho que ha sido un día histórico y
que estos creadores de contenidos o
youtubers deben de dar a conocer el
milagro salvadoreño refiriéndose quizás
a los logros en materia de seguridad sin
embargo
organismos como acción ciudadana han
criticado esta medida dado que lo que
busca dicen es potenciar el discurso el
discurso y la narrativa oficialista y
lavar un poco la cara este de cara las
próximas elecciones recordemos que este
2023 es es una es un año preelectoral y
necesitan afianzar el control de la
asamblea legislativa entonces de ahí
necesitan también mostrar una un mejor
rostro de la bancada oficial para
mantener el control de este órgano de
estado